well Jada look over there halt yes the
top three baby finally yes you've been
sitting on this secret for a minute
what's it like to finally get to sit in
the moment um I think that obviously non
the secret for a while
but the thing that's most important
after like is that I've been sitting on
this dream for even longer so to know
that I'm just so close to like making a
dream come true a mind is everything
it's hard to explain that Beach
[Music]
you've been so fun to watch I'm like you
came in a winner probably gonna leave a
winner let's pretend that crown is on
your head what's your message to America
after your name America's next drag
superstar I think the myth is for sure
to everyone is bad it doesn't matter
where you come from what your background
is how how long you've been working I
think that how many things you failed at
you can achieve anything I mean
literally like I did not finish high
school I had to go back and get like my
eight my GED and like it was one of
those things where so many things in my
life that told me you will not be
successful like where I grew up and all
these things um you will never amount to
anything but success is so many
different things to submit it to people
and I'm still found a way to find
success in my life just by pursuing my
happiness and my dreams now I chatted
with Trixie Mattel a couple weeks ago
and she said she was rooting for you her
milwaukee's sister it's hard to really
see anybody beating her because she's
good at everything and always and
literally I'm not kidding Jada has
looked like this since she like came out
of the box if Jade and I have been doing
drag since we were both like 20 her
voice is so funny to me I mean she just
has such a like chat out like a really
like child every other word and very
endearing she's a very endearing
speaking poise you tell me anything
about the old days in Milwaukee was yes
Trixie and I he when I first started we
both used to work at a bar in Milwaukee
and we were like like she was she was
kind of like a black sheep a lot of a
lot of people they did not understand
what she was going for and I'm not
probably completely I was like I don't
really get what it is that she is going
for but I was still here for the ride
you know I was along for the ride but we
both we both even audition for season
seven I auditioned and I was telling you
that like girl you're gonna make the
show and as soon as you get there you
are going to blow up in the world bike
gonna go crazy about go crazy about you
and she kept crazy enough she kept said
to me if you'll make it on the show I
won't go through it my brother
no way you will make yourself it's so
funny that we both saw something in each
other that we met each of us needed and
and I think that's why we appreciated
each other so much more I think you both
hit the show at the moment you were
supposed to be on the show yeah yeah and
I know we're gonna get a finale unlike
any other we've seen before this season
what kind of preparation did you have to
do for this finale oh I think this
finale I think that throughout the
course of the show people have expect up
they've seen a lot from me so for the
finale that
they obviously will be expecting a lot
for me so I think that it took a lot for
me to like go deep and explore parts of
myself that I probably never thought
that I could do like this look today is
something that's super conceptual
usually it's not something I probably
would have done but I wanted to do
something that was filled Lamm steel
myself but it's something that's still
with you the audience something that
they need no matter what we're going
through right now I still think that
they deserve a fantastic finale I want
to do some rapid fire about the season
okay what was your quote of the season
the line that it could be yours it could
be someone else's that the line that is
just that's the line of season 12 I
think yeah and what's the what's the
answer thing that you just like oh we're
going through the challenge and then
when I watch back and people kept
sharing us like oh my god this is really
becoming a thing now so but I'm proud of
it
it was definitely that's a moment yeah
that's like a drag racing forever now
thank you if you were to come back and
compete in an all-star season
well it's something you would want
redemption for to do better at a second
time around I think I would want
redemption for maybe for a comedy
challenge you know maybe maybe something
that was like with one woman maybe with
a stage maybe with an audience
something like that you know
who you are and I feel in the audience
know I can be a funny funny [ __ ] and
that type of situation you know um and
cuz baby she dropped the ball but it's
alright jump more than the ball does you
drop any liquid to I hope y'all had a
great time and that was the night that I
put the P in Padgett is there anything
you feel you need to apologize for from
this season yet oh I have to say to my
super a man outlook I love a man ain't
no bad love her so much and I say one
thing to get it out of the way for the
rest of this season situation it was a
light little shade because we're all
it's not like I just pummeled all my
life and when I was frustrated I'm like
since we both drop our lines obviously
we drop some of our line but obviously
the judges thought something special in
you and they've been asking for
something so that's why you're here
right now but with all the drama that
was going on maybe it would have been
better to have that conversation at a
later time
um so that she wasn't give me so much
you know but I love her so much
yeah I feel like it was you know the
competition can get the best to you at
times it's hot shangela I hope you still
have your phone card to middle-earth
because the hobbits are calling you guys
didn't really get to do the library
challenge this year we got to see like a
version of it with the box thing but is
there any read that you thought of this
season that you were like saving that up
for the library challenge that you
didn't get to use that you want to share
now I've really thought of reads and I
wrote them down in the notebook and then
they were so horrible but one of them
that I thought was kind of funny but it
was kind of not it was for GG is that
something something like this it's an it
make GG you're beautiful and statuesque
just like a mannequin and it makes sense
because you have the ass and the
personality of one very bad oh that was
pretty good they are pretty good yeah it
took me like seven hours to come up with
that one so it was it was worth it
alright
god bless good luck and look over there
yeah look over there
[Music]